alors bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
ce matin sur RT France alors quel
premier bilan peut-on faire du brexit le
Royaume-Uni a t-il vraiment tirer profit
de sa sortie de l'Union européenne selon
vous
[Musique]
chaîne de Italie
le problème c'est que il dit beaucoup de
choses pas seulement en ce qui concerne
le petit il a il a promis monts et
merveilles
moi
tout le temps
aujourd'hui
parler avec
avec les États-Unis avec la Chine
et
la Grande-Bretagne
de faire face à la paperasse tout d'un
coup qui est venu aux dépenses qui était
nécessaire pour ces nouvelles
réglementations les entreprises
européennes qui ont tous les autres pays
du marché unique comme comme client doit
être beaucoup moins motivé pour gérer la
paperasse aussi ils vont tout simplement
arrêter d'exporter vers la compote et ça
va se voir encore sur les rayons des
Britanniques il y a pas d' orange qui
pousse
beaucoup de salade par exemple donc ça
va se voir beaucoup plus sur les
mesures
anglaises
il faut des gens comme moi qui sont va
moi je vis en France mais longtemps
comme beaucoup de britannique
a changé beaucoup de choses
qui est britannique et ils
[Musique]
ne peuvent plus
qui sont venus s'installer en France ou
en Espagne et les Britanniques il y a
beaucoup de retraités qui ont voté pour
le brexit nous pouvons plus profiter de
cette libre circulation
des éléments clés de d'identité
européenne donc je crois que c'est
plutôt pour les chaussures génération
les jeunes à 80 % pour rester dans le
ils ont perdu
tout à l'heure
pendant 3 mois
€